[Musique]
la création de cette mission vient de
une crise sanitaire sans précédent une
crise sociale est aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que c'est que d'être un citoyen français
qu'est ce que c'est que d'avoir des
valeurs de la république à défendre donc
c'est l'interrogation que l'on aura à
travers cette mission car on constate
effectivement qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'incivilités parmi donc les élus locaux
qui suivit ce ça au quotidien qu'il y à
une défiance des mesures est aujourd'hui
en faveur des élus qu'ils soient locaux
d'ailleurs ou nationaux donc cette
mission aura à traiter tous ces sujets
dans le cadre de l'initiative
parlementaire ici au sénat chaque groupe
politique a la possibilité de solliciter
la constitution d'une mission
d'information sur une problématique
particulière
c'est ce qu'a fait le groupe rds heures
en s'intéressant donc bien ressort de ce
qui fait aujourd'hui l'abstention et
plus globalement d'élargir le sujet à
l'ensemble de la des questions liées à
la citoyenneté et c'est ce sur quoi la
mission va se pencher elle est
constituée de 21 sénateurs que ces
classiquement 19 on a deux suppléants ce
qui prouve d'ailleurs l'intérêt des
sénateurs pour pour ce sujet là les
principaux sujets traités iront
essentiellement en direction des jeunes
comment construire le futur citoyenne à
travers bien sûr l'éducation au niveau
scolaire mais aussi à travers donc la
journée citoyenne de défense on évoquera
bien sûr le service civil service
national a connaissance c'est la
première fois que le sénat se penche de
manière aussi précise sur cette question
de la citoyenneté nous irons creuser
vraiment tous les aspects de cette
question avec déplacement terrain nous
espérons pouvoir rencontrer des acteurs
très très fort sur le terrain pour faire
aussi des propositions ce qui est
important de comprendre ce qu à l'issue
de ces auditions déçu de ce travail
parlementaire il ya des positions des
propositions qui doivent voir le jour et
pourquoi pas être formalisée dans un
texte de loi